[Music]
it's just a
really tight-knit ocean-loving community
everybody generally has the same sort of
healthy ocean lifestyle vibe
it's what makes this area so unique
scott bass has called san diego home for
over 40 years
i love living here you're so close to
what really amounts to the largest
national park that we have which is the
pacific ocean it provides a lot
of fulfillment
san diego is a coastal oasis for its
beautiful shoreline
and marine wildlife
just below the surface is a coastal view
of iconic animals
like the california sea lion and the
official state marine
fish the hard to miss garibaldi
sitting atop the food chain are sharks
historically interactions between sharks
and humans are rare
but in 2008 a horrifying incident occurs
there was a lot of disbelief this hadn't
happened
in san diego in over 50 years
it was a sad day
it felt like summertime it was a
beautiful san diego day
in the early morning scott bass was
paddle boarding along fletcher cove
about 15 miles north of the city of san
diego
he's near a group of triathletes in
training among them
is retired veterinarian dr dave martin
dr martin was swimming with his
triathlete group
they were approximately 150 yards off of
the
surf line but somewhere below the group
a predator takes aim
a shark sinks its teeth into dr martin's
legs
and launches him out of the water
he screams for help
[Music]
everyone in the water is stunned
it was very surreal
people were scared
dr martin disappears underwater
[Music]
finally the shark releases its hold
and the group pulls dr martin back to
shore
first responders race into action
i remember the helicopter came right
above me and just boomed down on me
there's been a shark attack please get
out of the water immediately
but for dr martin the injuries to his
legs are too severe
before he can be transported to a
hospital
he succumbs to his injuries
[Music]
the tragedy captures the attention of
southern california residents
there was a lot of police there there
was a lot of media there there was a lot
of shock
there was a lot of sadness there was a
lot of despair
and news outlets cover it worldwide
you know it's a big deal you know there
hasn't been a shark attack a fatal shark
attack in san diego and something like
50 years
residents are stunned since
1970 the area has averaged about one
attack every three years
but dr martin's fatal incident in 2008
is just the harbinger of things to come
in 2009 a sudden spike takes hold
six attacks in only seven months i'm
sure
any number of parents were concerned
people were
trying to figure it out
[Music]
[Music]
you